the sweatshop boys have you rid like
your your career is on like this crazy
upswing moment right now and I know
you've been like working forever and
like trying to get here get here get
here but everything is like hit all at
once with with ro1 coming out and uh the
night of and and and the Bourne movie
and everything is it tough for you to go
back to sweat shop boys after that or or
do you go like I have to focus on this
um no it's a pleasure and it's my
priority really I mean that's what I'm
here in New York doing the whole in
November with touring and it's not even
so much go back to sweat your boys
because sweatshop boys is something
that's come to fruition for the first
time right now
he aims and I actually connected when I
was researching for the night of I had
to play a character from Queens right so
he hit me up and on Twitter like a while
ago before that and when I got there I
was like oh yeah that guy rapper from
Queens I linked up with him
so we clicked right away you know we've
got a lot in common
the way we see the world our backgrounds
our kind of life stories in a way almost
we just done opposite sides of the
Atlantic so we connected right away and
and we've been recording a little bit on
and off over the last couple of years
but we really put the album together
with our producer Rodino this May with
the whole thing in five days and Wow
yeah we work pretty quickly that's how
they used to be recorded like in 1971
like Sabbath to their first album in
like twelve hours like people people
didn't [ __ ] around back then it's a good
save money yeah especially before it was
digital it was like everybody was you
pay for studio time you're paying for
tape you're paying for all this stuff so
they get it done quickly as possible
exactly this time we're paying the price
of you know of teams is anga if we don't
finish just as expensive I like to get
in and get it done quick yeah so you're
not you know like a million take dude
you like a couple of them you don't know
I just try to get it done quick and try
not to think about it too much and try
not to listen to it later and try not to
remember it for stage shows and wow
that's exactly how my assets right
listening he just likes finishing yeah
that was a direct studio coders yeah and
I don't like listening like a really
inconsiderate lover just not listening
exactly here clean off your face on the
way out the door yeah so there's no like
there's no there's no going back and
being like I think I could do that word
better let me try to do that line better
me that's the user to me in him so I'm
like that guy who literally stays up to
4:00 in the morning the next day after
we finish the album going guys I think I
mispronounced that word and the games is
like meanwhile already cooking up like
you know a three-course meal for us like
going what track knew you need that you
need balance of one guy who is obsessed
with it and then the other guy who's
like dude relax it's good because then
you find the the truth is probably
somewhere in the middle absolutely and I
always joke that these guys of the UNAM
yang even though they go a lot of
commonalities they are very different
personalities as well so they're just
sizing us up right now that makes sense
though they're both wearing white caps
and have brown skin I mean how different
can be a part I didn't notice but thanks
for mentioning we're colorblind in this
yeah you know we only see souls by the
way I gotta say the four lions [ __ ]
amazing
thank genius man thank you so so good to
take like it to take such a hard subject
to be funny about and make such a
hilarious [ __ ] film I mean that was
just awesome oh thank you man well yeah
I mean that that kind of combination of
humor with politics is something that I
think isn't done enough because people
are sometimes scared to do it and
actually it's a really great way of
Trojan horsing some humanity into
conversations that become polarizing and
stale and that's really kind of what
we're doing with sweatshop boys as well
it really is kind of it's kind of a
political album but it's caught a lot of
jokes on it it's a lot of fun ready nose
beats are really hype so in that same
kind of way we hope it walks that line
between slightly comic and absurd but
like political and hard-hitting as well
so do you ever worry that a or do you
think in terms of okay if I say
something that somebody doesn't like on
this album are they gonna cast me in
this movie you know what I mean like
when you're when you're dealing with
political stuff as fickle as Hollywood
is and as much goes into casting that
doesn't necessarily have to do with the
acting does that worry you
well I think two points really first of
all that ship
sailed a long time my first track was
called the post 9/11 blues and it was
banned in on British radio while the
print and um because he had rhymes like
you know post 9/11 get around can cost
you some cash it cost twelve dead Iraqis
for a gallon of gas and you know it kind
of feels like gallows humor you know
we're all suspects so watch your back
cuz I'll fall I don't got arrested for a
chemical attack this kind of thing well
right ban that oh that's thank you you
should be the controller of the BBC I've
always said this about my like maybe say
when did that come out though that was
2006 okay so there's a little bit
removed yeah by five years laters five
years from 9/11 all okay well you know
that guy's like number five years ago
those guys are so high um no I mean so I
mean look first of all I've been kind of
you know speaking my mind about stuff
and uh the thing is uh I've said spoken
my mind the whole way through my career
and and I like to think I do it in a
kind of humorous way a thoughtful way in
a way that brings people in rather than
alienating them and pissing them off I'm
not getting up on a soapbox and giving
anyone a lecture so you know I think
people respect if you have opinions as
long as they're well thought through and
put put across in a considered way if
you do it through your work yeah that's
why that's what's great when an artist
does it through their work whether it's
through like I don't know if Chris wrote
for lions but well he wrote it with them
Sam Bain and Jesse Armstrong who write
on veep and who also wrote peep show up
so they're kind of comedy legends yeah
for American listeners who don't know
Chris Morris he's kind of like the
Keyser söze of British comedy he's you
know he's like this mythical dark knight
who kind of sweeps in and out causes
controversy and then bounces for a
decade yeh did that big thing about that
like some fake pedophile documentary or
something or whatever news was it
yes brass I yeah real cult kind of
series that you did yeah nobody just
drops it and then retreat so we I got
that I was called Peter gettin something
like that's a fake a news show called
Peter giddy and which team is gonna
freestyle about now
No you also probably like have to be
okay to talk about the stuff like if you
bring something up whether it's in on a
record or in an interview or whatever it
is you'd have to be okay to talk about
it we had Nancy Grace in here you know
Nancy Grace before you came in and she
walked out within seven minutes because
12 was it 12 yeah when she walked out
after 12 minutes he's making a BBC jokes
alone man kind of my leg I think that's
the first thing is that yeah you do it
do we work do it thoughtfully people
respect it but by also think look if
there's a kind of film franchise or a
network or some kind of you know
platform that is so sensitive and so
anti controversy that they don't let
people have opinions and they're
probably not going to cause someone like
me anyway who doesn't fit them all right
you know I'm already kind of fine myself
kind of on the periphery of what is the
standard mold of casting because I'm not
a white dude six foot two blond hair
blue eyes so I'm already kind of like uh
in a kind of political position just by
being me and looking like me being born
in a certain body in a certain space and
time right so politics is already landed
on my doorstep from day one you know so
it's like so when you get there is not
like I'm going out of my way to be
political that's something you inhabit
anyway how like controversial is it
really to be like I'm a brown dude and
these are my experiences it's not I mean
it's the fact that we're even talking
about it as as something that could you
know jeopardize the career what's what's
the what's so crazy yeah you're right
about your experience there's no place
for that in art but you don't you don't
like when you get cast in in Star Wars
for example you're not like Disney like
are you have you looked into like
everything I've done you're sure we're
gonna do this right but what see again
but why do you think that the head of
Disney will be calling me up saying
listen could you turn the dial down on
the brown and me like I cause he doesn't
mean exactly like what is that I mean
how is it's never the head it's always
somebody but there's always somebody
panicky it that way yes it's never the
head guy
actually hear about it when it's already
down the road the contour all the guys
at Lucasfilm are amazing Kathy Kenny I
mean look these are the guys who decided
that the next star was film rogue one is
populated by a lead role of a girl a
second leader of a Hispanic dude and the
supporting cast is Forest Whitaker black
dude me a Pakistani two Chinese dudes
and a robot it's pretty diverse right so
again I got that robot in yeah yeah
robot appears yeah yeah totally
um what is Forest Whitaker doing who is
he playing um oh you're not allowed to
say well I'm probably know how to say
but like the quick as Google would tell
you so I try that I think I just
shouldn't tell you cuz you should
research that no you know what I never
gue really guessed
I'm delighted towards the sound like I
want to thought it was like an artistic
reason for like Larry King stuff like no
I dunno research as part of my method
yeah I wanna I want to really my goal
here in life is to try and get him into
it into a Star Wars movie because I feel
like he'd bring a lot to the table do
you want to do you want to act Eames uh
he does act he said I do like I look
like that stuff here and there but more
than anything I just want to play a guy
that could shake down for information on
like a law and order doing practicing
once I would do that would be like yes
iam sometimes gin and tonic sits over
there that's the extent of that's what
I'm aiming for us that's your bucket
list yeah yeah but I don't know if you'd
be very effective in the Death Star you
know it's like they're coming huh
gives a [ __ ] boss grab this drink will
you fans of those films growing up
that's such a stupid question but it's
like you know my generation was come 48
you know it's like dude do younger
people like you know watch those or they
don't hold up ya know they definitely
hold up it's kind of part of us shared
like you know heritage it's just just
you know film mythology everyone's kind
of schooled in it I remember was the
first film I saw like kind of watching
him on VHS you know with my big brother
I didn't have a clue what was going on
mm-hmm
but I remembered you know those asshats
and you know those little Ewok s--
yeah the gold bikini and those I
remember all those
it was like wow it really does it
introduces you to animals to machines to
sexuality like it's all in a Star Wars
universe yet - good and bad that's right
that's right watch won't be a part of
that - good I did I didn't have anything
to throw something in superior boy here
all the guys talking well yeah yeah he
said the good bad guy yeah that guy's
got morals yeah yeah he pointed out
something no one thought of do you think
the culture that we're in right now is
it lends itself to a good time for you
guys to be putting music out
specifically with Trump and everything
that he's been saying I mean um
it's weird because we people have been
saying how timely the album is but we
kind of deal and deal in these things
think about these things live through
these things all the time and it's kind
of unfortunate that it's timely right
it's a reality for us all the time it
just so happens that we made this album
the same clip stuff that we've been
working on for four years and then this
happens in America and that happens in
the UK with brexit and even you know him
being Pakistani myself being Indian
there's a lot going on in India and
Pakistan right now - that makes the
album somewhat timely but for us it's
just a constant reality and now it seems
to be getting more media attention and
then might die down for like a year or
two and then it'll pop back up but it's
that's just the media attention the
reality of it is consistent even [ __ ]
phenomenal radio voice by the way thank
you
phenomenal thank you Riz Hattie's my
morning voice nah let's go it's really
good babe my voice is [ __ ] horrible
and his words it's the worst killer
voice I know I'm very envious emanate
I'm here anybody that can like I want to
listen to that guy he sounds like he can
speak with authority like it doesn't
matter what you're saying like it's just
like yeah I trust it I trust him is a
good show no it's nice we're too mousey
douchebag definitely yeah
rizz how did you how did you react it
breaks it being past well you know no
pressure I just found that uh sad no I
was just thinking the people do we need
to give people a little bit of context
of who the [ __ ] we are and what we're
talking about here with the album with
like sweatshop boys was me and hims and
Rodino right right he's Indian from
Queens New York
I'm Pakistani from London so it's like a
cross-border cross cultural thing Rodino
amazing producer works people like
Hudson Mohawke all this kind of stuff
to pull together this palette of like
Indian you know Pakistani sounds mixed
with grime and hip-hop and trap music
and dance music and we did by the way we
were playing on your tracks before you
came in that's what it was Oh care to
listeners at home right cool and so the
album is called Kashmir and it is uh
guys I guess it kind of you know we live
in a time when people are forcing you to
choose you are this or that right you're
the for us or against us you left or
right you know and this is a kind of
celebration of like people who are mixed
up and are kind of in in between spaces
which is why the the album talks a lot
about airports you know when you're not
kind of in between space and people are
judging you for it I think the airports
are kind of good good example of that
but the reason I brought it breaks it is
because it seemed like and it seemed
like we have a possibility of a very
similar thing happening with Trump here
because it seemed like all the people
that I've spoken to that didn't want it
to be passed didn't think it was going
to get passed like they were all just
like no of course I won't get passed of
course and then you know you wake up and
boom there it is passed it's done it's
approved we're good and people were like
shocked by that which I found kind of
fascinating because usually you kind of
can gauge which direction a vote is
moving you know what I mean
yeah I mean that's first one lessons to
learn from briggsie for the Americans is
make sure you get out and vote
particularly young people I think like
you know a quarter of young people
actually went and voted right and like I
think over one like eighty percent of
young people wanted to stay in the EU
and it would have swung the vote so it
is yeah I mean count and vote cuz I
think the fact is probably a lot more
people want to vote for Trump then or
admitting it right now I mean I don't
know I'm not America you gonna see that
on I mean that's a lot of the parallels
that have been made yeah it's
interesting because the underlying ideas
like I know this is racist so I don't
want anybody to know that I know this is
racist but when I'm in that booth alone
I'm gonna vote for brexit or Trump right
alright so I don't think it's
necessarily racist to vote for him I'm
still undecided and I know it's not I
don't think it's unfair as an example of
what you know the reasoning being all
right people associate him with this so
I don't want people to know I'm gonna
write societally and for me it might be
racism but whatever that point
welcome he's offered many ways to offend
people yeah he pick and choose but I'm
interested to hear because this is
something I hear from other people they
kind of put up this moral equivalence
between the two as if like well Hilary's
kind of corrupt too yes I guess she's
probably as dodgy as any seasoned
politician who has had to cut deals and
be in public life for that amount of
time has been but we're not talking
about a level of corruption we're we're
talking about like someone who has
strategically bankrupts himself time and
time again just to rob from people who
has been taken to court for refusing to
like you know sell condos to black
people has like several allegations of
sexual assault recordings just come out
of him saying was the grab [ __ ] and
move on [ __ ]
like well I mean at what point it's
cause Mexicans rapists he wants to do
like a kind of Holocaust aisle
registration of Muslims I mean at what
point do we go yeah maybe that guy's a
little bit more messed up he's not more
messed up than the rest of them I don't
think honestly because I find most of
them in that biblical can you name me
anyone else who has got that particular
gourmet collection well he'll crazy [ __ ]
Hillary Hillary's husband has been
accused of rape he was our president
been accused of rape I mean bill
Clarinda even includes the rape no but
he's all I'm just saying is even if
accused of rape by like hundred loads of
different people
he's never accuse rape socialism armed
yet as if anything Clinton built the
point of making says she took the moral
stance uh but I thought she did well in
the debate but she took the moral stance
if that's who Trump is he's not fit but
it's like that's if that makes you unfit
then how are you not entering out your
own husband who will use this again I
don't any problem with him doing that
but it's like you can't take the moral
high road on one and then ignore like
you know he bashed her husband who's
going to be the first gentleman he
shouldn't defend her husband it's almost
like doesn't that call it a question her
judgment and she's accused of
threatening city on that the only one
like morally the Obamas I don't think
behave that way I think Obama's got a
very clean sexual history but for him it
was how could you be friends with
Jeremiah Wright how could you there's
always a bunch of shitty connections and
shitty things in their past Trump is
just not a seasoned politician so he
hasn't learned how to beautifully talk
his way out of it the rest of them have
amazingly smooth on palatable and
malleable answers he doesn't have those
you spit use your language of a
fifth-grader so it's easy to appeal to a
larger group of people when your words
are simples this thing is good but that
thing is bad well there is something
about that when you're used to people
like the problem we have with most most
politicians is that you never feel like
you know where any of them stand good or
bad like the issues I don't believe any
of them yeah brother you know I hear you
about kind of you just I just want to
kind of as I'm from an outside of the of
America perspective I just want to let
you know that like the argument you're
making to everyone outside of America
I'm gonna speak further as the world is
bonkers comes off as bonkers because
what we're talking about here is someone
who is a proto-fascist if someone gets
up and says if someone got up a
candidate got up and said you know what
we need to register all Jews and we're
not gonna let any more any more Jew or
any more gays into the country that's
[ __ ] up and we go wow this person's
following in the footsteps of Hitler
because it says some says it about
someone who's a group that already
demonized is a kind of like legitimized
hate group we're kind of going well yeah
maybe we should register or miss Muslim
that it completely flies in the face of
the fundamental principles that America
is based on which is why America is is
so admired and so many people want to
comment because it has this sense of
openness and absorbing all that is good
in the world and by erecting those
boundaries and saying yo if you're part
from this group we don't want you we
want to lock you up we want to kick you
out that's not just racist
that's an American and to say that up
front that yo the elections are rigged
and to call into question the legitimacy
of the system just because he knows as a
risk of him losing again we're talking
about a protoboard fascist did you see
what happened to with debbie Wasserman
Wasserman Schultz and Bernie Sanders the
Democratic Party [ __ ] consciously [ __ ]
Bernie Sanders sure who I also liked
because he felt like he was about the
outside yeah and people miss Reid
Americans are wiser there's something
appealing about Trump it's not about him
demonizing brown people that's not but I
find appealing about him at all but what
I dislike that you don't find that like
a complete like you know red line
through here but not really cause here's
what that's not a red line he's crossed
here's what I see that as he is just not
he just spits stupid things out the
reactionary things that he thinks he
should be President
I should have the new
koats there again the nuclear codes he's
not gonna push a nuclear button these
two narcissistic to wanna kill me so he
has more reason to live than Hillary and
I was [ __ ] a hot woman Hillary's
husband cheated with everybody slide
behind Trump's got more reason to stay
alive in Hillary there's a bizarre it's
not as cut and dry as people think
Americans and not liking Trump because
like well he's going to boot the
Mexicans out nobody thinks that's going
to happen nobody wants to see Muslims
registered but he seems like some sort
of an answer for the blindness of
political correction and being PC I
think is very dishonest and there's
something that feels honest about him
even if it's wrong and I think that's
what the honesty is what you hit on so
there's this bizarre where I'm finding
is I just think is weird that we're
talking about someone as be this guy is
being honest when every every objective
fact checking attempt on any of his
speeches statements claims his figures
are more crooked than that wig like he's
complied any kind of scrutiny or
fact-checking under any of the
statements he's made I've come up as
nonsense like at the debates in
interviews people go you said this he
goes no I didn't you've got him on tape
they're saying like so the idea that
Trump is honest is kind of bonkers to me
the alley is obviously really amended he
honest about why he transparently
dishonest he's I was not on he's honest
about the way he feels about it
like he's again he's a reactionary guy
he says things but he's honest about his
opinions on things and then you can you
can determine what you want to do about
that like I mean I don't know mately I
am biased but I mean like forgive me if
I'm part of a kind of an ethnic group
the risks being registered and
exterminated by the person number
because nobody was transparently
dishonest I mean like cool but I mean I
just think I just think it's it's scary
time okay but it's not about that like
what people like like if bomb and again
it may be a strategic thing so I kind of
give Obama I'm not 100% sure on white
like they don't say Islamic terrorism
because they're afraid of being
offensive and said is this just said
what are you doing it you're not being
straight about like if the problem was
if you if you go you see the problem is
Italians you say the problem I don't
understand why that's seen as racist to
just speak honestly about something and
then that's the problem he's he's kind
of a mirror to how bad the rest of them
are like I wish he was if Bernie Sanders
had gotten through I would have a
part time choosing between Bernie and
Trump I would have a hard time Hillary
I'm still not sure I still may vote for
her bro I respect your honesty and
that's an interesting insight into like
you know it just shows how disillusioned
people are with the political
establishment there there was exactly a
willing to vote in a monstrous clown so
I respect your honesty there be any
worse terrifying yeah I know people are
scared but again Obama's a very genuine
guy and he want to close Guantanamo he
couldn't get it done George Bush like
him or hate him was genuine about the
fact he hated abortion and he couldn't
get that and you know they only have so
much power with checks and balances he's
not gonna wreck the country the
Democrats hate and the Republicans can't
stand him
he's not gonna push the button and kill
everybody but he's a great [ __ ] you to
the rest of them that's why I like him
and maybe that's childish but that's
what I like about it screws everything
up and there's also something rigs it
was about it was like well you know I'm
gonna shoot myself in the face to piss
everyone else of Rights like the the
counties and the in the groups
socio-economic groups that voted most
heavily for briggsie are the ones that
are in greatest receipt of EU funding so
they though they're they're the counties
in the areas and the groups in the UK
they're going to be the most financially
screwed over by brings it the ones who
voted for it the most and the same way I
think if you know the kind of the
underclass and a working class who
feeling squeezed right now by inequality
if they think that a billionaire that
inherited is money and strategically
went out to lost their and robbed people
six times straight is some blue-collar
hero
good luck that's also true yeah I don't
believe that either like that the fact
that that that is how disillusion people
are with it the fact that all of a
sudden you're right a billionaire is
seen as the guy who understands the
working-class Hilary is much better I
think for the average working-class
at least I think she cares more about
the average working-class person that is
yeah on that yes absolutely
on that note new sweatshop boys album is
out on Friday